greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
next in the confusion of your incredibly
peculiar holiday we are going to talk
about Christmas carols follow Allah
first who is Carol and why does she have
songs named after her
you never hear anyone say I want to go
solving tonight though I have heard
zombification believe why do people go
from home to home pestering innocents
while they sleep if five people came up
to my house and started singing I win no
Pam I always hear songs like Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer of Frosty the Snowman
fruits of nature why must we celebrate
these beats with song they should be
captured dissected and studied for the
benefit of mankind that way I can make
you more effective slaves singing about
these abominations isn't gonna make your
Christmas any jollier who is the
smartass that came up with the idea hey
why don't we bring the karaoke bar
outside butter
why don't we force it up every single
house we come across I won't be social
knocker that we won't even realize we're
freezing to death these fermented fruits
and vegetable drinks make me feel great
I can barely even feel my heart stopping
if we're lucky
maybe the pets are more fermented fruit
and vegetable drink so we can get
hypothermia even faster and I would note
the amount of songs that are dedicated
to that perverted fat German what's next
a song about John Wayne Gacy Jack the
Ripper no doubt how come there are no
Carol's about general solved I can think
of many good jingles that would involve
me here's one right now direct the holes
with we don't know I don't know I saw
the evil overlord was a very gracious
tyrant Joe Joe well I hate you Joe well
I can assure you you would love to hear
that play in the stores all day josh
groban you below me no wait I will blow
him with the power of my heat vision
what I will make an album out of these
songs that they will be a great hit I'll
call them songs zodmas songs try saying
that three times fast
I will not final summer Christmas carols
have no place in design Tony in People's
Republic of Houston they can jingle all
the way to the garbage can of my
discontent
this is General Zod and you will all
kneel
for me type the holes with Oh seriously
I think it'll catch up you will listen
to my get signals